are you gonna go host with Kelly are you
gonna fill in with Kelly don't look so
shocked Rob et has learned Rob Lowe is
in talks to join Kelly Ripa at the live
desk
a source tells us ABC has been talking
to the actors reps again I know back in
2012 when they were looking and ended up
finding Michael I know that your name
was in the running I know this for a
fact I posted it with Kelly
mm-hmm and had the time of my life I
love her I love being able to talk to an
audience every morning like that just
being fun counterpunching being silly
talking about cool stuff my kids are out
of the house they weren't then who knows
but listen man I don't want to go up
against the Anderson Cooper I don't want
Anderson's already got a gig he's got in
every day get okay cuz I don't wanna you
know I want to mess with him I don't
want a message center at the entertainer
I don't I don't want trifle with him
take that I think you could take them no
are you gonna sit in are you gonna guest
host god I don't know if I'm going to be
able to go back and actually the guest
host yeah you never know yeah